hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry I'm
Kitty dupois yes speak last remember
you're a woman
all right I mean you Chris Pratt's three
phases of Jurassic world acting on my
favorite TV host Conan O'Brien my
girlfriend's coming through the doors I
hear some noise that's going on scare a
lot and the movie you must have really
worked on your scared face yo yeah yeah
oh Jesus is your awesome
that was it that's all you got the whole
Buddhist oh geez oh geez oh that was you
yeah you just the face that you give is
really just you should do nothing that's
the key really yeah because if they cut
to like a birthday cake the audience
should think I think he's hungry for
birthday cake right things
instead they cut to a 60-foot dinosaur
chasing you know I bet you he's scared
right now right the music helps and the
edits and all that stuff the worst thing
you can do is overact because I've also
heard I've not done I'm not a movie guy
but I've heard that those movie cameras
they blow up your face for the real 30
feet high when they see it in a movie
theater and so that it's if if I was a
movie actor and they got in really close
and it's just like people would say
that's the worst acting of all time no
air laughing because that was very very
very good very good very good
a lot better but what do you like what
are you doing you're doing something
much I did I had that I had three phases
and I did on this one can we see him is
it your sphere
okay you want to see look love yeah and
then I had like like just pure joy
uh-huh so much
so because my my love would have been
like
what I need more you don't have to say
love but yes again just give us a little
more that there's another reason I'm not
at movies is that I yell out loud your
motion why is it walking oh that was
great : listen the characters not
British and also you don't have to say
the imodium
ah [ __ ] love Conan [ __ ] love Chris
Pratt but two together
BAM bomb sandwich that's what I say
after seeing Jurassic world I kind of
agree with Chris Pratt was all Universal
right there's a lot more than that but
I'm like yeah you know it kind of does
have that like stare a lot of the time
in the movie you know a lot of the
action heroes now like your job is to
not react too much to anything because
you're so cool and stoic that you don't
really read cuz nothing fazes you cuz
you're cool exactly exactly he's kind of
got a point
Katie would you sleep with Chris Pratt
yes yeah I mean I think most people
would ya know um I went no like
nomination you're embarrassing no really
there's like nothing to banter off of
here no really strange I would call me
know he's married I think he is it yeah
I was on Affairs yeah it wouldn't stop
me hey would you were just not the woman
I know I'm a good girl okay
my mom's convinced you it you would too
yeah if he came up to me is like hey you
know you won't have sex I'd be like yeah
sure just Travis so cat you're so demure
really yeah I feel that way about jock
I'm so honored first Pratt wants to yeah
okay or Jeff golini I'd beyond I'm so
honored that you think of me Ed O'Neill
Ed O'Neill zag Randy sit no no I feel a
little scared are you punch me in bed oh
no I believe he was probably a gentle
lover your virginity
it was taken cue laughter haha anyway
guys thanks for tuning in
battery's gonna die you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out Jerry
I'm reason to Jerry and ain't gas Stubbs
you can check out Katie on the Katie du
bois channel follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine because if we
get enough
followers more product placement